je suis en train de finaliser un
bracelet
il est le symbole d'une famille en fait
le deuxième enfant va naître d'un jour à
l'autre
à l'image de ce pendentif
les trois quarts des ventes de
christelle moreau sont des commandes de
bijoux personnalisés
forcé de fermer à nouveau sa boutique la
jeune joaillières profite de ce deuxième
confinement pour travailler ses
créations j'essaye de de produire plus
pour noël plutôt d'essayer de faire des
vitrines où les gens pourront - commandé
parce que malheureusement au moment où
ils vont pouvoir venir
j'aurais pu le temps de faire les
commandes proportionnellement laps de
temps
donc là j'essaye plus de faire une
vitrine où les gens pourront acheter
directement les pigeons j'essaye de
métier il faut s'adapter on n'a pas le
choix on ne peut pas se dire on peut pas
passer son temps à déprimer à se dire
que ça va marcher il faut absolument que
trouver une autre solution
donc il faut se motiver il faut faire
marcher les réseaux sociaux et et se
faire connaître autrement
christelle crée des bijoux depuis
qu'elle a 7 ans elle a commencé par les
perles et après avoir étudié au lycée
professionnel de saint amand montrond
dans le cher
elle s'est spécialisée dans le travail
de l'or avec le confinement
elle peut difficilement acheté beaucoup
de ce métal si précieux
l' avantage du métier aussi c'est que
parfois les gens fournissent le rendre
donc ça permet d'avoir moins de matières
premières a avancé maintenant pour tout
ce qui est vitrine bien entendu c'est
c'est un mois de la danse est vrai donc
bah on s'arrange aussi avec les
fournisseurs qui sont très compréhensifs
dans l'ensemble n'a bref tout le monde
est assez solidaires et et c'est plutôt
plaisant confinement signifient perte de
salaire total pour christelle mais elle
reste optimiste
son portefeuille clients compte 150
personnes de quoi lui assurer des
commandes régulièrement passer le cap
en tout cas si elle peut ré ouvrir début
décembre le mois le plus important de
l'année pour son activité